[Music]
right now north las vegas police
investigating a shooting at a house
party over the weekend they tell us an
argument led to gunfire it happened near
lone mountain and simmons late on
saturday night two adults and two
children were hurt one of those victims
is known to be a mcdonald's all-american
star basketball player she's a senior at
spring valley high school and sally
jeremiah live there at that location
with an update on how she is doing sally
gales is a five-star recruit and those
who know her on a personal level
describe her as a sweet grow with a big
heart and a lot of love for basketball
mark mosley is the vice president of
ball dogs a local media company that
showcases basketball talent he has known
gaels for four years and is in shock
after hearing aaliyah gails was shot 10
times as a monday she has had three
surgeries mosley as well as other
friends and family are glad to hear she
will recover and want to see her on the
court again i thought you know
you know never know when you what will
happen but it's
off too often have been happening lately
probably just getting shot up it's just
something that shouldn't be happening
going on it's crazy because she's always
on the court already in the gym always
trying to lower up get to new places new
new tricks in her bag mosley added she
plans to play basketball at usc one of
her dream schools
now police have not arrested anyone just
yet a gofundme has been posted to help
with medical expenses if you would like
to help visit our website
eightnewsnow.com reporting live sally
jaramillo live local now